saying okay i was i was worrying about  myself oh wow we see a queen sacrifice  by yana pontiacci  um i said anything wins it does look  like this is winning as well  black has given up his queen for a rook  and a knight but  black's remaining pieces are dominant  black's rook is gonna drop down to the  bottom of the board and win white's  queen  it's over gary resigns he's about to  lose his queen and be down a piece  wow the drama of the final in the magnus  crossing invitational we are going to  tie breaks ladies and gentlemen  a fantastic comeback by janna pomnyacci  saves him the tie breaks and anish giri  is still sitting there  he must be so disappointed maybe with  his opening to